[Musique]
bonjour je suis atisbé conseiller
municipal à la ville de poissie et
aujourd'hui je vais vous faire découvrir
le plus grand caniparc de la région donc
nous sommes au canipark hashiko à
carrière souspissi ou hashiko pour ceux
qui souhaitent aspirer le ha
allons-y
alors et c'est
parti
[Musique]
bonjour kine bonjour àtis Merci beaucoup
donc de nous accueillir aujourd'hui au
Canny Park à Chiko alors est-ce que tu
peux nous préciser comment est venu
cette impulsion cette volonté de créer
ce cannyarc à carrière s pooissi depuis
2020 la mairie a une politique
volontariste en faveur du bien-être
animal et le la création du cannyark
s'engage en fait s'inscrit dans une
politique un peu plus large sur la place
de l'animal en ville et sur la place de
l'animal domestique et l'animal sauvage
et c'est depuis 2021 avec une
consultation citoyenne que l'idée du
parc a un peu émergé on nous av demandé
en fait au caerrois leur avis pour
savoir si euh ils étaient intéressés
s'il y avait vraiment un besoin sur le
territoire d'un canyark euh et c'est à
suite de cette consultation que euh le
canyark et euh et et sa création grâce
au département euh a pu être concrétisée
sur la ville est-ce que tu peux nous
dire nous décrire un petit peu en fait
le Cany Park avec ses agréés je suppose
qu'il y a un règlement une gestion en
terme d'agré euh il y en a cinq donc il
y a des ha des tunnels rigides des
balançoirs et aussi des des saut
d'obstacle de manière générale permett
d'avoir plusieurs types d'activités qui
sont disponibles pour pour les animaux
et en terme de règlement c'est un
règlement qui est assez simple les
chiens doivent être contrôlés par les
maîtres les déjection doivent être
nettoyés aussi par les maîtres également
et c'est un un espace qui est ouvert de
manière libre à chacun avec un ou deux
animaux de manière générale au maximum
par mètre et bien merci beaucoup Kevin
nous avoir reçu merci
[Musique]
fraya alors du coup est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quels sont les
avantages pour vous pour votre chien du
canyarc au niveau de sa santé au niveau
de sa cohésion sociale smog est un chien
qui a besoin de beaucoup d'activité en
fait donc vraiment bouger au moins 2
heures par jour courir et là c'est un
espace qui est libre d'accès et il aime
beaucoup ces activités qui sont
proposées tout à fait gratuitement pour
tout le monde
oui
[Musique]
donc le canyark fait partie de votre
parcours également est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un petit peu les
bienfaits des canyark ce qui est bien
dans le Canny Park c'est que c'est
clôturé et il y a pas tous les chiens
qui restent toujours avec nous alors là
ils sont en sécurité ça rassure les gens
de pouvoir laisser leurs chiens le point
de rencontre pour les chiens et et même
des chiens qui sont peureux ils
commencent à faire c'est très important
pour les chiens sont des animaux très
sociables et et c'est vrai que même pour
nous aussi on fait des rencontres on a
tous on a les même intérêts on échange
des informations des des astuces pour
les chien pour la nourriture et c'est
très agréable et vous venez donc par
tous les temps même quand il fait un
froid de chien puisque vous prenez votre
café juste après toujours il y a
toujours la Poste gourmande pour les
chiens et pour nous et c'est vrai que
quand il pleut quand tu es seul tu n'as
pas trop envie d'y aller mais vu que tu
sais qu'il y a du monde ici viens et tu
sais que le moment est là que quelqu'un
amène le chocolat chaud ou le café ou
l'apératif on vient voilà et ça motive
et c'est plus même s'il pleut on y va
parce que malheur partagé c'est c'est
plus facile ouis voilà et bien allons-y
allons rejoindre la foule allez c'est
partibineû
[Musique]
wou alors comme vous pouvez le constater
en ville donc les canyark sont des lieux
de sécurité vous pouvez promener votre
chien c'est des lieux qui permettent
d'avoir de la cohésion sociale pour vos
animaux mais également pour vous-même
voilà à très
[Musique]
bientôt